"
LIBERALS CITIES SPENDING
MILLIONS TO FIGHT THE HOMELESS
CRISIS BUT THE PROBLEM IS IT
JUST KEEPS GETTING WORSE.
THERE IS HEART BREAKING IMAGES
OF THOSE LIVING IN DEPLORABLE
CONDITIONS ON THE STREETS
BECOMING ALL TOO COMMON.
AS DEMOCRAT LEADERS GET ACCUSED
OF DUMPING BILLIONS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS INTO FAILED PROGRAMS
THAT DO LITTLE TO SOLVE THE
ISSUE, WE RAN THROUGH THE
NUMBERS AND THE AMOUNTS SPENT
ARE JUST STAGGERING.
SAN FRANCISCO SPENT AN
ASTONISHING $100,000 FOR
HOMELESS PERSON.
NEW YORK SHELLS AT $58,000 PER
YEAR FOR HER HOMELESS PERSON,
BUT IT HASN'T HELPED.
A RECENT REPORT SAYS
HOMELESSNESS IN THE BIG APPLE
HAS SEEN THE HIGHEST LEVEL SINCE
THE GREAT DEPRESSION AND CHICAGO
SPENDS ABOUT $9,000 PER HOMELESS
PERSON.
THE UNMANAGEABLE HOMELESSNESS
PROBLEM PUTTING THE McDONALD
CEO IN A TOUGH SPOT.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO ENTICE
EMPLOYEES BACK TO HEADQUARTERS
IN CHICAGO AND CALLED ON CITY
AND BUSINESS LEADERS TO ADDRESS
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE ARISEN SINCE
THE PANDEMIC.
>> EVERYWHERE I GO I'M
CONFRONTED BY THE SAME QUESTION
THESE DAYS.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN CHICAGO?
THERE IS A GENERAL SENSE OUT
THERE THAT OUR CITY IS IN
CRISIS.
THE TRUTH IS IT'S MORE DIFFICULT
TODAY FOR ME TO CONVINCE A
PROMISING McDONALD'S EXECUTIVE
TO RELOCATE TO CHICAGO FROM ONE
OF OUR OTHER OFFICES THAN IT WAS
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO.
TO BE ONE JUDGE, WE CAN TALK
ABOUT ANY AMERICAN CITY BUT YOU
KNOW CHICAGO VERY WELL.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S HAPPENING
FOR OTHER BUSINESSES AS WELL?
>> Jeanine: ABSOLUTELY.
I GIVE HIM CREDIT.
I GIVE THE CEO OF McDONALD'S
CREDIT FOR MAKING AN ISSUE OF
THIS.
THE BIG CITIES ARE IN CRISIS BUT
NOT JUST THE CITIES ON THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVED THERE, BUT
BUSINESSES ARE NOW RECOGNIZING
THE IMPACT THAT CRIME HAS ON
THEIR BOTTOM LINE.
THAT'S WHY IF YOU DON'T HAVE LAW
AND ORDER, THEN WHAT YOU HAVE IS
ANARCHY.
THEN YOU HAVE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE.
THIS HOMELESSNESS, IN ADDITION
TO THE LOOK THAT IS UNSAVORY --
I MEAN I KNOW PEOPLE WE SENT TO
JAIL FOR LESS THAN $106,000,
WHICH IS WHAT THEY PAY IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
THE ISSUE IS WHAT ARE WE GONNA
DO WITH THESE PEOPLE?
SOME OF THESE ARE CRIMINALS WHO
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH AT THE
GENESIS OF WHATEVER CRIME THEY
ARE INVOLVED IN.
BUT EVERYTHING IS IN CRISIS.
IT'S A VIOLENT CRIME.
IT'S DRUG ABUSE.
IT'S THE OVERALL DEPRESSION.
WE'VE GONE BACK AS A NATION A
GOOD THREE OR FOUR DECADES IN
TERMS OF INFLATION AND CRIME.
NOW THIS HOMELESSNESS, WHICH IS
JUST LIKE THE TOPPING ON THE
CAKE.
AND IT'S A SAD SITUATION.
THERE IS NOTHING ELSE THAT WE
CAN DO EXCEPT MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO RUN THESE CITIES
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT SAFETY ANYMORE.
IT'S ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT SPINS
OFF OF "LAW & ORDER."
>> Dana: THE NUMBERS SURPRISED
ME, GREG, HOW MUCH MONEY IS
SPENT PER PERSON.
IF YOU WALK AROUND THE STREETS
OF NEW YORK, SAN FRANCISCO,
DENVER HAS A HUGE PROBLEM, EVEN
SAN DIEGO AND LOS ANGELES, THEY
ARE SPENDING ALL OF THIS MONEY
BUT IT'S NOT WORKING.
>> Greg: I'M NOT SURPRISED.
LIBERALS LOVE THROWING MONEY AT
PROBLEMS BECAUSE IT'S NOT THEIR
MONEY, IT'S OUR MONEY PIT THEY
GET THE PARADE THEMSELVES OFF OF
THIS PHONY COMPASSION PAID
$807 MILLION WENT TO THE STRIVE
PROGRAM IN NEW YORK AND WE NEVER
SAW IT AGAIN.
I DON'T THINK THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS ACTUALLY
EXISTS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO SPEAK
THESE UNSPEAKABLE TRUTHS.
BUT THAT MEANS YOU HAVE TO BE
RISKED BEING CALLED
UNCOMPASSIONATE, HEARTLESS, AND
COLD.
THE UNSPEAKABLE TRUTHS ARE THIS.
A MAJORITY OF LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS ARE AT THE MERCY OF A
FEW THOUSAND, 10,000, 50,000,
MAYBE HALF A MILLION NATIONWIDE,
OF PEOPLE WHO EXIST INDEPENDENT
OF OUR RULES, LAWS, AND MANNERS.
WE HAVE DEFINED A HEINOUS
LIFESTYLE, HOMELESSNESS, AS A
LIFESTYLE CHOICE.
I'M SAYING EXEMPT FROM THE TINY
EXCEPTIONS, RIGHT?
I'M TALKING LARGELY MEN -- WHEN
YOU SEE THESE PICTURES THEY ARE
MOSTLY MEN.
THEY ARE NOT HANGING OUT LIKE
THE JOVIAL TRANSIENTS AND HOBOS
YOU USED TO SEE IN CARTOONS.
THESE ARE STRUNG OUT, MANIC,
UNFRIENDLY, AGGRESSIVE PEOPLE.
YOU ARE LUCKY IF THEY ARE
UNCONSCIOUS, BECAUSE THEN THEY
WON'T HURT YOU BUT I WALKED THIS
CITY ALL THE TIME.
I DRIVE UP IN THE MORNING.
I COUNT THEM, I RECOGNIZED THEM,
I KNOW THEM.
THEY DON'T PREFER SHELTERS TO
THE STREETS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T DO
DRUGS AND SCORED DRUGS IN
SHELTERS BEAR THAT'S WHY THEY
ARE OUT THERE.
THAT'S A CHOICE.
YOU CAN'T BRING YOUR PROPERTY
INTO THE SHELTER EITHER.
THEY DON'T ALLOW THAT.
SO YOU PREFER TO BE OUTSIDE WITH
YOUR BAGS OF STUFF AND DO YOUR
DRUGS.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS SPEND ONE
AFTERNOON IN NEW YORK CITY AND
YOU SEE THE REALITY.
IT FLIES IN THE FACE OF
EVERYBODY THAT IT TELLS YOU YOU
HAVE TO BE MORE COMPASSIONATE.
THERE COMPASSION IS ALLOWING
THIS TO HAPPEN.
THEY ARE LIKE THE TOURISTS GET
THAT GIVE THE HEALTHY BEGGAR
WITH THE LITTLE DOG MONEY AND
THAT BEGGAR IS IN FRONT OF YOUR
HOUSE.
IT'S LIKE I WANT TO GO TO YOUR
HOUSE WHERE YOU ARE IN GERMANY
OR SPAIN AND DO THE SAME THING
AND SEE HOW YOU FEEL BECAUSE ALL
YOU DO IS YOU KEEP THESE PEOPLE
HERE MAKING MONEY.
I DO HAVE A SOLUTION, IT'S A
PROGRESSIVE SOLUTION.
GIVE THE HOMELESS WHAT THEY
WANT.
THERE IS NO WAY YOU CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
YOU CAN'T REASON WITH THE
UNREASONABLE.
GIVE THEM WHAT THEY WANT, BUT
NOT IN THE CITY.
THE CITY ALLOWS THIS TO HAPPEN.
MOVE IT ONTO GOVERNMENT PROPERTY
AND LET THEM RUN IT.
CAMP AWAY.
GIVE THEM THE AUTONOMY TO TRULY
RUN THEIR LIVES INTO THE GROUND,
HARM EACH OTHER, DON'T HARM US
ANYMORE.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING YOU CAN
DO.
IT CAN'T GET ANY WORSE THAN IT
IS NOW.
YOU HAVE TO MOVE THEM TO A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN LIVE THEIR LIVES.
>> Geraldo: SO FEDERALLY
FUNDED OPIUM DENS WITH THE
HOMELESS --
>> Greg: I WILL BE MAYOR OF
OPIUM TOWN.
>> Dana: I WANT TO POINT THIS
OUT, IN SAN FRANCISCO THEY
DISTRIBUTED 206 NEW TENANTS
ACROSS SIX LOCATIONS.
THE TENTS WERE A TOTAL OF
$16.1 MILLION.
THAT'S ABOUT $61,000 PER TENT.
YOU CAN GET A REGULAR TENT FOR
ALIKE -- A GOOD ONE FOR LIKE
$300.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN WALK INTO
REI AND GET A TENT ON SALE FOR
$300.
BUT THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO IS
CHARGING $61,000 PER TENT TO THE
TAXPAYERS BEAR THAT'S CRAZY.
THE SAN FRANCISCO OFFICIALS ALSO
USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO BUY
LIQUOR AND BEER FOR THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE.
THEN THEY GOT CAUGHT.
LOOK WHAT THEY ARE DOING IT ALL
OF THESE NONFOR PROFITS.
THE PROFITS ARE GOING TO THE
SCAM ARTISTS THAT RUN THEM.
THEY TAKEN $10 MILLION TO HELP
THE HOMELESS AND WHAT DO THEY DO
WITH THE MONEY?
THIS WOMAN WENT ON A SHOPPING
SPRAY.
YOU'VE BEEN THERE A FEW TIMES,
JUDGE.
THIS IS SOME OF THE NICE S
LUXURY SHOPPING ANYBODY WILL DO
AND ANOTHER GUYS TOLD ABOUT
$5 MILLION AND HE DOES KICKBACKS
TO CONTRACTORS AND THEN GIVES
HIS FAMILY MEMBERS THE RUN OF
THE PLACE.
IT'S ALL A HUGE SCAM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS BEER THEY WANT TO
KEEP THE PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
SO THEY CAN FLEECE THE TAXPAYER.
WHY ARE THERE SO MANY HOMELESS
PEOPLE?
THEY EMPTIED THE PRISONS, SHUT
DOWN THE ECONOMY, BROUGHT IN AND
ILLEGAL ALIENS AND DECRIMINALIZE
DRUGS.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO HAPPEN?
I WOULD UNDERSTAND GREG'S POINT,
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE RIGHT NOW.
TAKE SOME MONEY, GO GET AN HOUR
AND A HOTEL.
TAKE A SHOWER, DO A SHAVE, THEN
GO TO THE BARBERSHOP.
GET A LITTLE BIT OF HAIRCUT.
THEN GO TO THE THRIFT SHOP, GET
A BUS TICKET, AND GET OUT OF THE
CITY AND THE WAY FROM ALL OF
THESE DRUGS.
GET YOURSELF A JOB, GO TO SLEEP,
READ A BOOK, TAKE A WALK, DO
SOME PUSH-UPS, SAVE SOME WATER,
SAVE MONEY FROM EACH PAYCHECK,
THEN CALL YOUR PARENTS.
YOUR PARENTS WILL COME TAKE YOU
END.
>> Greg: NONE OF THAT WILL
EVER HAPPEN.
>> Dana: I DO THINK, GERALDO,
YOU CAN BE A COMPASSIONATE
PERSON AND ALSO FEEL COMPLETELY
HELPLESS AS YOU WALK AROUND.
>> Geraldo: THE BITTER IRONY,
DANA, IS THE MORE SERVICES YOU
PROVIDE THE MORE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THERE WILL BE.
PLUS WHO DOESN'T WANT TO LIVE IN
SAN FRANCISCO OR VENICE BEACH?
I REMEMBER DURING ED COCHRAN'S
ADMINISTRATION THEY USED TO GIVE
OUT BUS TICKETS.
WHERE DO YOU WANT TO GO?
ANY PLACE BUT HERE APPEARED
JESSE'S IDEA IS NOT THAT
OUTRAGEOUS.
THE WHOLE NOTION -- IT GOES WITH
GREG'S IDEAS OF NOT IN THE CITY.
ANY PLACE YOU WANT TO GO, WE'LL
GIVE YOU A WAY TO GET THERE.
NOT UNLIKE TEXAS AND FLORIDA ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW, BUT I THINK THE
IDEA OF SOME KIND OF ENCAMPMENT
OR SOME KIND OF IDYLLIC PLACE
SOMEPLACE -- BUT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE SOME PAYBACK.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR INSTANCE, MY BIG BEEF WITH
PROGRESSIVES IS THEY DEMAND
NOTHING OF THE RECIPIENT.
WHY NOT SOBRIETY?
WHY NOT DRUG ABUSE COUNSELING?
WHY NOT GETTING YOURSELF CLEANED
UP?
YOU CAN'T HAVE ANYONE EVOLVING
OUT OF THAT SORRY CONDITION IN
LESS YOU GIVE THEM SOME
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Jeanine: THEY DON'T WANT
THAT.
WHEN I USED TO SENTENCE SOMEBODY
I WOULD SAY TO THEM DO YOU WANT
TO GO TO JAIL FOR A YEAR OR DO
YOU WANT TO GO TO REHAB AND
STRAIGHTEN YOUR LIFE OUT?
THEY'D RATHER GO TO JAIL.
SO THEY CAN COME OUT AND DO WHAT
THEY DO AND WHAT THEY LIKE.
>> Dana: AND FAMILIES --
SEVERAL FAMILIES ACROSS --
SEVERAL, THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT THEIR
LOVED ONE IN REHAB MULTIPLE
TIMES, DURING THEIR RETIREMENT
SAVINGS, AND STILL END UP WITH
SLEEPLESS NIGHTS WONDERING WHERE
THEIR CHILDREN ARE.
>> Greg: WHAT GERALDO IS
SAYING IS IN THE OLD DAYS THEY
HAD -- THE INSTITUTIONS WERE OUT
OF THE CITY BECAUSE THE CITY IS
STRESSFUL FOR SANE PEOPLE.
IMAGINE BEING -- LIKE YOU ARE
HOMELESS AND YOU HAVE A MENTAL
ILLNESS.
LOUD NOISES, BUSES, TRAINS, WHY
ARE YOU HERE WHEN YOU CAN
ACTUALLY BE -- THERE IS A REASON
WHY PEOPLE GO TO NATURE.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
DONE, BUT AGAIN YOU SOUND LIKE
YOU ARE SPEAKING OUT OF LACK OF
COMPASSION BY SAYING MOVE THEM
OUT.
WE ARE SAYING THEY ARE NOT
HELPING THEMSELVES, THEY ARE
DESTROYING THEMSELVES AND
OTHERS.
>> Jesse: IF TRUMP HAD BOD
GREENLAND IT WOULD'VE BEEN T